so if you look at life like starting
today or starting tomorrow
when we leave here today
there's a bunch of trajectories
that you can take through life
may be countless
do you think some of these trajectories
in your own conception of yourself some
of those trajectories are the ideal life
a life that uh if you were to be the
hero of your life story
you would want to be like is there some
joshua bach that you're striving to be
like this is the question i ask myself
as an individual
trying to make
a better world in the best way that i
could conceive of
what is my responsibility there
and how much am i responsible for the
failure to do so because i'm uh
i'm i'm lazy and incompetent too often
in my own perception
in my own worldview i'm not very
important
so it's uh
i don't have place for me as a hero in
my own world
i'm trying to do the best that i can
which is often not very good
and
so it's not important for me to to have
status or uh to be seen in a particular
way it's helpful if others can see me or
a few people can see me that can be my
friends no sorry i want to clarify the
hero i didn't mean status or perception
or
uh like
uh some kind of marketing thing but more
in private in the quiet of your own mind
is there the kind of man you want to be
and would consider it a failure if you
don't become that
that's what i'm meant by hero yeah not
really
i don't perceive myself as having such
an identity
and it's also sometimes frustrating
but it's basically a lack of
of having this notion of father that i
need to be emulating
it's interesting it means the leaf
floating down the river
i worry that um
sometimes it's more like being the river
i'm just a
fat frog sitting in a leaf
i know
on a dirty muddy lake
waiting for a princess to kiss me
or the other way i forgot which way it
goes somebody kisses somebody
you